[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour cette vidéo
l'anatomie comparée pour les nuls et les
végétariens je sens que je vais me faire
des amis avec cette vidéo la section
commentaires ça va être
délectable aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de gary young ski un végétarien
qui a fait une conférence il ya quelques
années qui est très populaire sur
internet notamment un petit passage où
il parle de l'anatomie comparée et de
l'évolution humaine et will
avant on va dire la réalité et les faits
scientifiques pour que ça défendent le
végétarisme
alors cette vidéo ne va pas être à des
bonnes cage contre les végétariens ça va
pas être une vidéo on va casser du
végétarien ça va être une vidéo où il
sera question de quelqu'un qui retourne
des arguments pour les faire s'accorder
avec ses opinions
donc il se trouve que la personne en
question est végétarienne ça c'est
plutôt un dommage collatéral en réalité
on est bien d'accord
ceci n'est pas une vidéo pour taper sur
les végétariens ou les vegan ce que
j'essaie de vous montrer à travers cette
vidéo en fait c'est la pertinence les
arguments d'anatomie comparée et
d'évolution humaine dans des débats de
société comme justement celui sur le
végétarisme qui a en ce moment il y à de
très très bons arguments pour être
végétarien voir vegan le petit bout de
conférences que je vais commenter
aujourd'hui est d'ailleurs extrait d'une
conférence bien plus grande qu'à donner
gary europe's qui et qui contient très
certainement des arguments qui
pourraient vous combattre mais
aujourd'hui c'est pas de cela qu'on va
traiter on va traiter de ceux qui ont
été perverties si vous voulez des bons
arguments pour être végétarien vegan
voici une vidéo ce que vous pouvez aller
voir y en a beaucoup d'autres
c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est que ce
monsieur en se cachant derrière le
végétarisme avance une révision de
l'évolution humaine une révision de la
biologie et de l'anatomie humaine qui
pervertit complètement nos connaissances
voilà on nous en tant qu'enseignant
derrière ça on passe notre vie à passer
derrière des gens comme ça à passer
derrière des gens comme lui pour tout
corriger
évidemment les étudiants comme ils
gobent tout ça très très facilement
parce que c'est parce que c'est présenté
avec le vernis du végétarisme donc le
vernis delà de la condition morale juste
donc un message tout mignon et bien
politiquement correct comme il faut à
nous comme derrière comme on passe
derrière et ben fatalement on passe pour
les méchants
voilà on est les monstres les villes
incarne east ah non non c'est pas parce
qu'on est car nist ont rétabli la vérité
et c'est pas bon c'est pas de notre
faute si la vérité va pas un sens du
végétarisme en sciences on se doit
d'être matérialiste et une vérité
matérialiste il y en a qu'une alors que
des opinions il y en a des millions donc
passé derrière un mec comme ça c'est
juste un cauchemar systématiquement mais
on peut le tourner à notre avantage en
tant qu'enseignant parce que justement
on suscite l'intérêt des étudiants et ça
c'est ça c'est quelque chose justement
que j'aimerais montrer à travers cette
vidéo c'est qu'en suscitant en faisant
appel à un débat qui est public et qui
est houleux et qui suscite beaucoup
d'intérêt eh bien on peut s'appuyer là
dessus pour pour générer des
connaissances pour générer de
l'éducation et je pense que c'est un
moyen comme un autre d'arriver à créer
de l'impact monsieur gary obs qui semble
penser que la fin justifie les moyens et
qu'on a droit de pervertir la vérité à
condition de défendre des opinions juste
et bien moi je me propose de vous
montrer que la fin justifie les moyens
et qu'on peut prendre des gros débat de
société bien polémique pour faire de
l'éducation soit 25.2 vraiment
le premier argument de monsieur gary you
up ce qui est sur la longueur des
intestins la testa serait très long chez
les êtres humains environ 7 à 13 fois la
longueur du torse comme chez les
herbivores
alors à quoi sert un longue intestins
chez les arts vivants et bien tout
simplement à digérer la cellulose la
cellulose qui se trouvent dans les
fibres végétales est extrêmement dur à
digérer contrairement à la viande la
viande ne nécessite pas allons système
digestif et je suis prêt à croire gary
europe ce qui quand il nous dit qu'au
contraire il faut même plutôt l'évacuer
assez rapidement avant qu'elle vous
moisissent dans l'intestin
donc je suis d'accord avec lui de ce
point de vue là les habits bord peuvent
se permettre un plus long système
digestif que les carnivores et se
doivent d'avoir un plus long système
digestif que les carnivores
pourquoi et bien parce que les fibres de
cellulose sont extrêmement dures à
digérer donc vous avez besoin de lait
mastiquer longtemps dont vous avez
besoin de bronze dans de gros muscles
mastic ateurs vous avez besoin de les
faire fermenter très longtemps et c'est
pourquoi vous avez besoin d'un très long
aux intestins ou d'un estomac à quatre
poches
donc les ruminants ont opté pour une 10e
une digestion dans l'estomac avec quatre
poches dans l'estomac alors que les
chevaux et la plupart de tous les autres
herbivores y compris les primates
herbivores d'hier avec leurs intestins
et c'est pour ça que l'intestin si c'est
parce que vous avez besoin d'une énorme
chambre de fermentation quelque part
dans votre anatomie pour pouvoir briser
ces molécules de cellulose alors il faut
bien définir ce qu'on entend par
longueur des intestins ce qu'il ne fait
pas chez les arbitres bord les intestins
sont effectivement très très long de
l'ordre de 13 fois la longueur de
l'animal chez cheval à 20 fois la
longueur de l'animal chez la vache
en revanche chez les carnivores comme le
chien qui n'est d'ailleurs pas le plus
carnivore de tous les carnivores mais
bon on va le prendre comme référence
chez le chien on est à quatre fois la
longueur du corps pour l'intestin donc
la testa et de toute façon très long
chez les chez les animaux qu'ils soient
carnivores ou herbivores selon gary
young ce qu'ils oublient de parler c'est
qu'il y a aussi des omnivores et que c'
est omnivore comme le cochon par exemple
ont un intestin qu'il fait à peu près
onze fois la longueur du corps donc les
valeurs de l'homme 7 à 13 fois la longue
du torse tombe confortablement autour de
la valeur du cochon alors je précise
nous parle de la longueur du torse pour
l'humain au lieu de la longueur du corps
pourquoi parce que pour comparer à des
quadrupèdes faut pas mesurer l'humain du
bout des pieds au bout de la tête donc
pour ça je suis d'accord
chez les quadrupèdes on mesure la
longueur du corps du bout du museau à
l'arrière-train ce qui est ce qui est un
peu plus comparable à la longueur du
torse chez l'homme autrement si vous
mesurez la longueur totale de l'homme on
a un intestin 9 m pour 1 mètre 80 ça
fait à peu près cinq fois la longueur du
corps donc là on tomberait
définitivement dans les valeurs du chien
mais c'est faussée par le fait qu'on
mesure des pieds du bout des pieds au
bout de la tête donc pour le coup sa
méthode est relativement rigoureuse par
contre l'argument ne marche qu'à moitié
puisque l'être humain dans ce cas là a
des valeurs qui sont très proches du
cochon avec néanmoins la valeur la plus
haute si on en croit gary robes ski
atteignant celle du cheval donc on peut
lui accorder un demi point
on peut lui accorder un demi point sur
ce coup là par contre ce dont il oublie
de parler cdu c'est comme le sait comme
c'est ap
c'est un petit compartiment au début du
gros intestin qui est complètement
atrophiée chez l'homme puisqu'il forme
l'appendice et chez les arbitres bord le
caecum est très développé puisque ils
forment une chambre de fermentation pour
la végétation justement parce que la
végétation on a tendance à l'oublier
mais manger de la végétation est
beaucoup plus dur que de manger de la
viande parce qu'il faut briser les
fibres de cellulose qui sont extrêmement
coriace
contrairement à la viande qui est très
facilement digestible donc la viande se
digère plus facilement que les végétaux
et c'est pour ça que les herbivores ont
besoin d'une chambre de fermentation et
d'un longue intestins donc l'humain
intestins de longues heures qu'on va
qualifiée de moyenne mais une absence de
ces comme ce qui pointerait plutôt vers
un régime omnivore attendant ce
carnivore si on se basait uniquement sur
ce caractère est en réalité avec le même
argument que lui et c'est là c'est là où
ça devient un petit peu feu tendancieux
c'est que monsieur gary offs qui
manipule la biologie avec énormément de
rhétorique et il arrive à tourner ses
phrases de telle façon à enfumer un peu
la vérité mais en réalité si je reprend
l'argument de gary aux hawks qui je peux
tout aussi bien dire que l'être humain
est carnivore
avec le même argument je vous sors que
l'être humain n'a pas quatre estomacs et
il n'a pas de c comme
donc c'est un carnivore si l'argument
vous gêne c'est normal c'est pas parce
que je suis car nice tous de mauvaise
foi que l'argument ne marche pas c'est
parce que l'argument n'est pas bon et
garry gross qui utilise exactement le
même mais dans l'autre sens donc il faut
faire très attention c'est de la
rhétorique pur faut pas se laisser avoir
par cette rhétorique pur le système
digestif humain pointe plutôt vers un
régime de tendance omnivore avec une
petite pointe de karni vori pour ce qui
est de l'absence du c'est comme et une
petite pointe derby vori pour ce qui est
de la longueur de l'intestin qui est
effectivement un petit peu plus longue
qui peut être effectivement un petit peu
plus longue que celle de l'omnivore de
base
je rajoute qu'il serait très facile d'en
valider mon argument en prétendant que
les quatre estomacs sont typiques des
ruminants les ruminants c'est uniquement
la famille des vaches des chèvres et des
chameaux donc c'est effectivement à
caractère qui est très limitée en
réalité chez les arts vivants
le fait d'être ruminants le cheval les
rhinocéros tous les primates qui sont
herbivores
il digère avec leur c'est comme parce
qu'ils n'ont pas justement ce système à
quatre estomacs
donc on distingue chez les arbitres bord
deux grandes catégories que sont ceux
qui digère avec le caecum donc avec la
partie intestinale de leur système
digestif et ceux qui digère avec leurs
quatre estomacs les ruminants comme on
tord la biologie pour la faire
correspondre à des idéaux au final
l'argument est mauvais arguments
suivants france vont freiner une nuit
qui le traite avec chrome de ruz
nerazzurri au mieux parce que dans le
vieux-mans youtube ses meetings
elle participera gary souhaite voir post
coureurs oui non trente mille tonnes
coureurs il nous parle de la possibilité
de boucher ses artères quand on est
carnivore et de la possibilité dessus et
quand on est herbivore
alors seulement les arts vivants
verraient leurs artères se bouche et non
pas vraiment puisque les omnivores aussi
il ya que les carnivores qui sont
strictement immunisés encore que je
devrais vérifier si les ours et les
pandas le sont aussi
peut-être par héritage de leurs ancêtres
mais voilà est par contre je ne vois
absolument pas d'où vient l'argument de
la sueur ni ce qu'il a à voir avec le
débat
je vous avoue que ça me passe un peu au
dessus est ce qu'il essaye de nous dire
que les que l'humain est biologiquement
plus proche des arts vivants en
utilisant l'argument de la sueur qui n'a
rien à voir je ne sais pas dans ce cas
là on pourrait dire que ça il a été
depuis longtemps établi que le cochon
est biologiquement très proche de nous
ainsi que nous le sommes des autres
primates puisqu'ils sont le plus proches
parents ça prouve rien pour ce qui est
du régime alimentaire à les griffes là
on touche à un argument pertinent pour
l'anatomie comparée donc la forme du
stade des phalanges est bel et bien un
indice qui permet de reconnaître un
herbivore d'un carnivore
quand on ne connaît pas le reste de son
anatomie donc qu'ils soient faux cils ou
modernes si vous trouvez des glyphes
globalement c'est vrai que c'est plutôt
un indice de karni vori oui mais il y à
des exceptions il y à moult exceptions
les rongeurs sont des herbivores avec
des griffes les cochons sont des
omnivores avec des sabots andrews arcus
le plus grand mammifère carnivore qui
ait jamais existé avait des sabots pas
des griffes
alors pourquoi on se retrouve avec des
arbitres voir avec des griffes ou des
carnivores sans glyphes c'est parce que
les grippes elles ont aussi ce qu'on
appelle un très fort signal
phylogénétique dans leur anatomie
l'anatomie allez faites de plusieurs
composantes
la première composante c'est
effectivement l'adaptation c'est à dire
l'adaptation à l'environnement ou au
régime alimentaire dans ce cas là mais
il ya aussi le hasard des mutations et
aussi la pile
jenny votre anatomie ne sort pas de
nulle part vous avez des ancêtres et ses
ancêtres avaient eux mêmes une anatomie
et si vos ancêtres étaient herbivores
comme ceux d'andrew arcus qu'on appelle
les condyles artres et bien vous avez
une anatomie d'herbivores et il se
trouve que les hommes ont des ongles
parce qu'ils sont des primates et que
tous les primates ont des ongles c'est
une adaptation à l'arborer cholil avons
hérité de nos ancêtres
mais ce n'est plus vraiment une
adaptation pour nous nos ongles ne nous
servent à rien pour grimper aux branches
donc monsieur youssef qui confond
adaptation et atavisme la part de notre
anatomie qui n'est pas directement issu
d'une réponse à l'environnement mais
dont on ne peut pas se débarrasser parce
qu'il faut bien qu'on descende de
quelqu'un donc attention à ne pas vous
faire enfumer parce que monsieur a
travaillé sa rhétorique il oublie de
vous préciser que les griffes ne sont
pas que adaptative alors une fois de
plus des arguments qui ne touchent pas
l'anatomie comparée donc on va passer
dessus rapidement pour la millas donc
les enzymes qui permettent de digérer
les glucides est connue et que nous
produisons dans notre salive
je suis d'accord pour dire qu'elle est
absente chez les carnivores mais encore
une fois monsieur use de rhétorique en
omettant de préciser qu'elle est
présente chez les omnivores
donc le fait que nous synthétisons de
l'amylase n'invalide pas le fait que
nous pourrions être des omnivores chaud
et enfin on a taclé dans les dents le
deuxième grand indice la pierre
angulaire de tout raisonnement qui
permet de reconstruire le régime
alimentaire d'une espèce à partir de son
anatomie uniquement donc monsieur
d'harry europe's qui nous signale que
les dents humaines sont larges courte
émoussé et plates comme celle des autres
herbivores vérifions si cela est le cas
c'est l'heure de parler de
classification dentaire alors les dents
des mammifères peuvent être divisées en
six grandes catégories la première
catégorie sont les dents dit bras qui
donc c'est à dire les dents à couronne
basse les dents humaines sont
typiquement des dents bras qui danse
puisque
un courant de basse et à croissance
définit une croissance qui s'arrête à
l'arrivée de la maturité sexuelle
à l'opposé des dents bras qui donc on
trouve les dents ips donc telle que
celle des chevaux donc les dents ipso
d'onde sont des dents à croissance
continue ou prolonger certains rongeurs
en aidant qui sont en croissance
continue
la plupart des herbivores ans des dons
qui sont seulement à croissance
prolongée c'est à dire qu'elle ne
s'arrête pas avec l'arrivée de la
maturité sexuelle et cela résulte en des
dents qui ont une couronne très très
haute des dents absolument gigantesque
comparée à celle de l'humain et ça ce
sont des danses typiquement herbivores
pourquoi les arbitres auront des dents
comme ça c'est parce que les végétaux
contiennent des fibres très difficile à
mâcher comme la cellulose et quand il
s'agit d'herbivores strict c'est à dire
des herbivores qui mangent des graminées
et bien les graminées contiennent des
phyto lite c'est à dire des petits bouts
de cailloux des bouts de civis en
réalité et 7 6
elle use les dents à un tel point que si
vous n'avez pas des dents à croissance
continue pas très rapidement vous vous
retrouvez sans dents donc ça c'est les
deux premiers types dentaire et on a
quatre autres types dentaire qui aurait
qu'il ne s'oppose pas à cette île
dentaire mais en réalité se superposent
heures donc le premier c'est le type
bruno dhont buno dont tu sais tu as type
dentaires ou l'écu speed sont
relativement ronde
émoussés et où les puces pid ont une
morphologie plutôt simple c'est
typiquement le cas chez le cochon ou
bien une fois de plus chez l'humain
ensuite vous avez le type lofo dont le
type lofo d'hôtes qui est ici
représentée par le rhinocéros
c'est un type de morphologie dentaire un
peu plus complexe où les culs speed sont
reliées entre elles par des lofts c'est
à dire des crêtes
vous avez le type celeno d'hondt où
cette fois le cul speed forme
décroissant d'où le nom selene ce qui
fait référence au croissant de lune
encore une fois c'est un type qu'on
retrouve chez les herbivores comme chez
la vache et le dernier type c'est le
type seco d'onde ou les danses ont
transformé littéralement en couteau
c'est le type dentaire des carnivores
traits typiquement alors l'homme comme
l'ours et le cochon est de type bracchi
buno d'onde
c'est à dire que ses dents sont à
couronne basse et accus speed be no
doubt c'est à dire relativement simple
et arrondies c'est un type dentaire
qu'aux rencontres
typiquement chez les omnivores et les
frugivores donc là vous avez l'exemple
de deux omnivore l'ours et le cochon qui
ont des morphologies dentaire très
proches de celles des hommes
alors pourquoi je précise aussi
frugivores parce que la plupart des
primates frugivores ont aussi des dents
raki bruno dhont ce qu'on rencontre chez
les arts vivants par contre ça va être
des dents ips dont tu es après on peut
avoir des combinaisons entre hip solofo
dont tu es ipsos et les noms d'autres
par exemple donc ipso seller no doubt
c'est un type dedans qu'on rencontre
chez la vache donc les dents sont à
croissance prolongée avec des culs speed
en forme de croissant
vous avez le type iep solo faut donc
qu'on rencontre chez le rhinocéros à
vous pouvez voir et on va assister là
dessus que la couronne est très très hot
vous pouvez voir sur cette section du
crâne de cheval que la couronne dentaire
s'étend à l'intérieur de l'os maxillaire
s'étend à l'intérieur des mâchoires de
façon très prononcé ce qu'on ne retrouve
pas chez les omnivores ou bien chez les
carnivores
de plus chez dans d'herbivores le dessin
dentaire est extrêmement complexe
il est fait de beaucoup de crête d'émail
avec un remplissage d'une matière qu'on
ne retrouve pas chez les omnivores où
les carnivores qui s'appelle le segment
donc entre les crêtes des mailles vous
avez un remplissage de ces man qui
augmente la surface de mastication et le
relief dentaire très complexe aussi
augmentent cette surface de matières de
mastication donc la couronne est immense
sa surface de mastication et accrue est
allé ornementé de dessin complexe chez
les herbivores donc en aucun cas la
morphologie des dents humaines ne
reflète celle des arbitres bord ceux que
gas rios qui nous décrit c'est une norme
d'omnivore ou de frugivores typique mais
en aucun cas d'herbivores donc ça ne
valide pas complètement son argument
puisque je voulais dit les frugivores
ont des dents qui ressemble beaucoup à
celle des omnivores
mais par contre définitivement pas
d'herbivores strict mais par contre les
dents humaines ne sont pas celles
d'herbivores strict la couronne est trop
basse le dessin dentaire est trop simple
de plus
j'attire votre attention sur les muscles
mastic ateurs regarder la surface
d'insertion du muscle massé terre chez
le cheval comparé à l'humain regardez la
taille de la surface d'assertions du
musée
massé terre chez le cheval comparer là à
celle de l'homme et du chien et vous
verrez que la taille des muscles mastic
ateurs n'ont rien à voir entre l'homme
et les herbivores donc encore une fois
je peux retourner son argument
complètement dans l'autre sens les dents
humaines sont à couronne basse simple et
les muscles masticatoire humains sont
relativement petit et dans ce cas-là
j'utiliserai la même paire ou est que
lui qui est d'oublier complètement qu'il
y a des omnivores ne faut pas seulement
à monsieur diouf qui nous fait remarquer
non sans condescendance que la plupart
des herbivores ont des canines et
effectivement je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ça vous voyez que je peux
être d'accord avec lui aussi à je suis
honnête dans ma démarche
effectivement il y a beaucoup d'arbres
morts qui ont des canines et même des
herbivores qui ont carrément des dents
de sabre à la place des canines en
l'occurrence elles servent surtout à la
parade amoureuse puisque ses canines
développés serve de caractères sexuels
secondaires et pas tellement pour
l'alimentation
mais effectivement les canines chez les
arbres morts il y en a et du reich music
live dub jazz quand le golden boy soir
la mastication alors permis aux hawks
qui nous dit que si vous mâcher vous
êtes un herbivore et là je suis obligé
de lancer le petit clip à cette fête
c'est faux archi faux si vous mâcher
vous êtes un mammifère les insectivores
match et ils se nourrissent de protéines
animales
donc ce n'est pas un caractère
strictement de mammifères herbivores la
mastication est commune à tous les
mammifères depuis 200 millions d'années
c'est pour ça que nous avons tous des
molaires c'est pour ça que nous avons
tous des joues
les joueurs retiennent la nourriture à
l'intérieur de la bouche pendant que les
molaires mastic la mastication ça a été
la grande clé adaptative des mammifères
les tortues ont leur carapace les
oiseaux ont des plumes les mammifères
ont des molaires qui leur servent à
mâcher si vous comparez un crâne de
mammifères à celui d'un reptile
vous pouvez très bien voir la différence
entre les deux les mammifères ont des
dents différenciée qui leur permet de
couper père s'est arrachée et broyer
leur nourriture alors que des types
dentaire qui permettent de faire ça
n'existe pas chez les reptiles parce que
la plupart d'entre eux avale tout rond
là où je veux en venir c'est que il n'y
a absolument rien de surprenant à ce que
nous puissions mâché ses deux réglages
par défaut de tous les mammifères
il n'y a guère que les cétacés qui ne
mâche pas du tout parmi les mammifères
donc arguments suivants locaux venus
porter secours au foot et kronenbourg
faible loyer chez skoda france henri iv
monument nocturne nos voisins nos quais
19e chine à la fin quand le bourg de
challenge on y voit john curran square
in you may be my guest hit de square à
nos femmes et d'enfants bilingues et
chinois paris paris et hawk ride depuis
guillaume il au delà de ces biberons
chiffre d'affaires des âmes et là on
passe aux défis alors l'édifice et c'est
un peu plus compliqué argumenté parce
que on rentre dans la mauvaise foi on
commence à rentrer dans la mauvaise foi
et là c'est de l'argument qui est
vraiment 100% rhétorique là il ya plus
vraiment d'anatomie derrière mais comme
on va pouvoir apprendre des choses à
partir de ces défis on va quand même en
parler un peu bon alors pourquoi l'homme
ne peut pas attraper un écureuil l'homme
et adaptés à la course de fond pour
traquer du gros gibier pas des écureuils
du gibier de grande taille pendant
plusieurs heures voire même plusieurs
jours comme le font les bushmen dans le
kalahari par exemple la station debout
minimise les risques d'insolation la
sueur abondante qu on sécrète refroidi
le corps l'absence de pouce opposable
sur mon pied est une adaptation à la
course
modifié à partir de l'anatomie d'un
primate de base ces adaptations ne sont
pas parfaites car on a deux gros reste
de l'anatomie de nos ancêtres les grands
sages qui eux étaient arboricole la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes pas
adapté à courir après les écureuils
c'est tout simplement parce que nos
ancêtres utilisaient leur intelligence
pour attraper le petit gibier et
notamment des pièges mais fort
heureusement on sait à quoi
ressemblerait un humain s'il était
vraiment végétarien un vrai humains
végétarien ça a existé
l'évolution nous en a donné un exemple
il y a environ deux millions d'années de
cela et c'est humain complètement
végétarien c'est pas rentrer opus qu'on
appelle aussi les australopithèques
robustes
on pense que par entre opus se
nourrissait de noix de fruits et de
tubercules alors le graphe que vous
voyez maintenant apparaître à l'écran
vous montre le temps en millions
d'années sur la colonne de gauche
les points rouges représentent le genre
homo les points jaunes représente les
parents trope et le point vert en bas
représentent les australopithèques alors
ce que ce grave vous montre c'est
l'évolution de la chimie dentaire chez
ces trois genres d'humains donc on a
analysé la chimie des dents fossilisées
de tous et genre humain et à partir de
là on en a reconstruit le régime
alimentaire puisque la chimie des
constituants de vos dents va être
différente en fonction de si vous êtes
herbivores omnivore ou carnivores donc
ce que vous voyez c'est qu'il y à 2
5 millions d'années australopithecus
sashimis dentaire recouvrer une large
part du spectre de variation ce qui
montre qu'il avait un régime alimentaire
plutôt généraliste donc définitivement
très omnivore mais que plus tard avec le
temps donc il ya deux millions d'années
ce spectre de variation se divise en
deux à gauche aux mots et à droite par
entre opus ce qu'on a là c'est une
différence de chimie dentaire qui
reflète l'adaptation à deux régimes
alimentaires différents à rentrer aux
puces va s'adapter à l'herbe ivory alors
que homo va rester omnivore avec une
légère tendance carnivore il va y avoir
ce qu'on appelle un partage des
ressources une partition des ressources
ce qui va permettre au genre ou mots et
où j'en repars entre opus de survivre en
même temps au même endroit mais sur deux
types de ressources différentes
il s'agit d'une partition des niches
écologiques
donc ce que ce graphe nous a dit que
c'est qu'il ya eu un moment de
l'évolution humaine où il ya eu
expérimentation de plusieurs régimes
alimentaires un régime plus végétarien
pour paraître plus un régime légèrement
plus carnivore pour homo et tout cela à
partir d'un régime omnivore ancestrale
chez australopithecus est aujourd'hui si
seuls homo persiste c'est parce que par
entre opus cet état alors là je voudrais
faire une petite aparté sur l'évolution
du cerveau il est très souvent avancé
que c'est parce que l'homme s'est adapté
à une nourriture carnet que son cerveau
s'est développée personnellement je
trouve que cette théorie n'est pas
extrêmement convaincante
pourquoi et bien déjà parce que la
viande n'est pas en soi un aliment
beaucoup plus riche la porte des choses
différentes mais l'apport de nutriments
brut et en particulier de glucides qui
sont si importants pour le cerveau n'est
pas aussi important et ne justifient pas
un accroissement de la taille du cerveau
à ce point en réalité la cuisson des
aliments a certainement été un facteur
beaucoup plus important dans
l'accroissement de la taille du cerveau
card
elle facilite grandement la digestion et
il ya aussi l'utilisation d'outils le
genre homo utilisent des outils pour
prédigéré sa nourriture
la digestion chez le genre mot n'a plus
lieu dans la lah plus lieu strictement
dans le tube digestif mais commence déjà
dans les mains et ça c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important au mot est le
premier à utiliser les outils de façon
extrêmement régulière non pas qu'il n'y
avait pas douter
avant mais au mot est vraiment le
premier à les utiliser de façon quasi
systématique et ses outils permettre une
pré digestion de la nourriture et donc
une meilleure assimilation des
nutriments
les premières traces de feu maîtrisé
apparaissent il y à 2 2,5 millions
d'années en afrique du sud et montre que
même si le feu n'était pas encore
domestique et dans le sens où on n'était
pas capable de leur faire nous mêmes ils
étaient déjà utilisés probablement pour
cuire les aliments ce qui permet aux
encore une fois de prédigéré la
nourriture avant de l'ingurgiter ce qui
encore une fois facilite la digestion et
l'incorporation de nutriments on s'est
probablement ces deux phénomènes qui
tous les deux conduisent à une pré
digestion des aliments qui ont permis de
soutenir l'accroissement de taille du
cerveau ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'ils
ont été l'événement déclencheur
pourquoi une nourriture carnet ne
serait-elle pas à l'origine de
l'augmentation de la taille du cerveau
donc sur l'île de sicile
on a retrouvé les restes fossilisés d'un
petit éléphant un éléphants nains qui
s'appelle paléo loxodonta lé conneries
donc l'éléphant d'un de sicile et cet
éléphant des deux siciles il pesait
environ 100 kilos pour un cerveau
d'environ 2 kg ce qui est très très
proche des proportions humaines les
proportions humaines c'est environ 80 kg
pour un cerveau de 1 kg 5
donc l'éléphant d'annecy s'il avait un
cerveau proportionnellement aussi grand
que celui de l'être humain
alors que on n'a aucune preuve qu'il
était carnivore autant qu'on sache
l'éléphant d'un de sicile avait le même
régime alimentaire que les autres
éléphants c'était d'un herbivore
strictes au cou peut tout à fait avoir
un gros cerveau et être herbivores pas
un problème
bon j'arrête ici la digression c'était
juste pour dire que voilà je ne vais pas
partir sur l'argument taille du cerveau
et intelligence on est forcément
carnivores parce qu'on a un gros cerveau
parce que à mon avis c'est pas un
argument valable
revenons à notre part entre opus est
justement qu'est ce qui fait qu'on pense
que par entre puce était un humain super
herbivores et bien c'est son anatomie
quand on regarde pas rentrer opus ici au
milieu comparé à australopithecus au
dessus et au mot homo habilis en dessous
eh bien on constate que par entre opus
d'une part à une crête sagittale et
déjoue extrêmement développé d arcade
zygomatique extrêmement
développer ainsi qu'un angle de la
mâchoire qui est beaucoup plus projeter
vers l'arrière et vers le bas que chez
australopithèques us ou homo habilis et
ça ça veut dire qu'il y avait des
muscles mastic ateurs extrêmement
puissant attaché à cette arcade
zygomatique à cet angle de la mâchoire
et à cette crête sagittale donc les
muscles mastic ateurs était très très
grands chais pas rentrer opus
un peu comme chez le cheval justement de
plus par entre opus à des normes dans
extrêmement plate est complètement usés
par la mastication des fibres végétales
ce qui va complètement dans le sens d'un
herbivore donc un humain complètement
végétarien ça devrait normalement
ressembler à ça un humain avec un visage
extrêmement large et plat d insertion
pour des muscles mastic ateurs
gigantesque une mâchoire absolument
gigantesque avec des normes dans à
l'intérieur et un gros ventre un gros
ventre pourri accommoder un intestin
très très long avec un c comme très
développée afin de faire fermenter les
fibres végétales et briser les fibres de
cellulose
un peu comme celle orangs outans donc
voilà c'est pas super sexy mais ce que
gary your love qui vous dit quand il
vous dit que l'humain est herbivore
il est en train de vous dire que vous
ressembler à ça là où je veux en venir
c'est que si vous vous laisser
convaincre que garry gross qui a raison
et que l'humain est un herbivore typique
et ben vous vous plantez l'humain a des
caractéristiques des herbivores parce
qu'ils descendent de singe un herbivore
qui sont devenus lentement omnivore
entre australopithèques us puis de ces
omnivore ont eu tendance à devenir
légèrement plus carnivore
dans le genre homo échappant ainsi à la
concurrence directe de leurs cousins
part entre opus qui eux étaient beaucoup
plus à vivre mieux
chiang mai avec la même expérience de
pensée je vous fais exactement la
déduction inverse placer un enfant de
deux ans face à un steak haché et à un
brocoli et vous aurez le résultat opposé
donc encore une fois ils essaient de
vous enfumer avec de l'anthropologie de
bistrot 000 wii just as
last but not least la théorie du complot
nous sommes conditionnés depuis notre
enfance pour ne manger que de la viande
on nous manipule la théorie du complot
c'est l'argument facile facile à
utiliser facile à retourner aussi je
pourrais tout aussi bien vous dire que
depuis notre plus tendre enfance
on nous manipule afin de nous faire
croire qu'être carnivores c'est mal
le méchant dans tous les dessins animés
pour enfants c'est le carnivore c'est
toujours le carnivore et même quand le
carnivore et par miracle un gentil donc
j'en sais un chat ou bien le roi lyon
par exemple
eh bien vous ne le verrez jamais jamais
mettre à mort du gibier
donc vous voyez moi aussi je peux créer
des théories du complot ou à la fin ce
sont les vendeurs de tout fou qui
finissent par vous manipulez l'argument
de la théorie du complot c'est le
alors évidemment que je n'en crois pas
un mot de ce que je vais me dire mais ça
vous montre à quel point c'est facile et
même simpliste comme argumentation
il rassemble et le petit bonus pour la
fin qui montre que soit il ne connaît
rien la biologie ce qu'il a juste choisi
d'ignorer complètement la biologie les
animaux ne font pas que filtré des
nutriments il les transforme avec le
même argument je pourrais vous dire de
bouffer la terre parce que les végétaux
ne font que filtrer les nutriments qui
sont dans la terre
cet argument c'est une aberration
biologique les animaux transforme les
nutriments vous êtes incapable de faire
comme une vache et de vous nourrir de
graminées toute la journée
si vous vous mettez à bouffer des
graminées comme une vache veau dans
seront massacrés en quelques jours par
les phyto lite qui se trouve à
l'intérieur
elles finiront usées jusqu'au sang et
vous allez crever d'une infection dans
les mâchoires avant même de mourir de
faim si vous essayez de vous nourrir de
la même chose qu'une vache donc la vache
transforme les graminées
donc en conclusion à tous ceux qui
cherchent des arguments afin de
rationaliser leurs choix de vie leur
choix moraux et leurs opinions
personnelles ou politiques
s'il vous plaît ne touchez pas à ma
science
foutez la paix à darwin foutez la paix
et à la science foutait la paix à la
biologie ils ne vous ont rien fait ne
vous ont rien demandé
la science c'est un corpus de fait qui
peut corroborer toutes les idéologies et
leur contraire si on sait manier la
rhétorique et uniquement si on sait
manier la rhétorique il n'est absolument
pas question de faits scientifiques
quand
vous voulez défendre une opinion il
s'agit simplement de la façon dont vous
les utilisez dont vous utilisez la
rhétorique pour les manipuler c'est
exactement ce que fait ce mec dans cette
vidéo et même s'il le fait pour des
causes défendable je ne crois pas qu'il
soit juste de manipuler les faits
scientifiques
donc voilà si vous n'avez qu'une chose à
retenir de cette vidéo c'est s'il vous
plaît séparer vos opinions de la science
autrement j'espère que vous aurez au
moins appris quelques petites choses en
anatomie comparer parce que c'était un
peu le but de la vidéo
quoi qu'il en soit je vous dis à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo ciao
[Musique]